what's going on everybody welcome to the
12th
yes well take inter tutorial with Python
in this video we're going to be doing is
adding this pop-up message function to
our program so the idea of the pop-up
message is just any time we call it we
just pass in some text and the message
pops up as its own little kind of
warning window or just just a message
window so first let's go up to the very
top and you see how we have large font
now let's go ahead and add a couple of
other font sizes so it's all a
conceivable that we want a large font
right then we want to you know a normal
font and then even a small font so we're
gonna call this one norm font and then
we'll call this one small fonts so small
font maybe some little directives
underneath something a caption something
like that normal font just for any
normal sort of text obviously large font
for big important messages announcements
that kind of thing so a normal font will
do size 10 and then small font will be
size 8 now let's go ahead and define our
popup message function just put it
anywhere basically but maybe you know
we've got the classes down here and
we've got functions up at top that's
just how I'm going to do it so now we're
going to define pop-up message and the
parameter is gonna be message and this
is gonna be like a like a really mean
tkinter instance basically but we'll say
pop-up equals T capital T on our case K
and then we're gonna say define and in
fact let's we'll leave that out for now
we'll come back to that so then we're
going to say pop-up WM underscore title
will do I guess we'll do this yet so
it's just gonna be an exclamation mark
like it's just a notification window so
the title is just exclamation mark then
we're going to say label equals T TK dot
capital L label and then the label will
be pop-up the text of that label will be
the message that's passed through as a
parameter and then the font used
we'll be norm underscore on then we'll
do labeled up Pat will do side really I
don't really I guess we'll do side top
because we'll eventually we might have
an okay but so side top and then we want
it to go ahead and fill the X and then
pad the Y's by 10 so Pat the edges
actually pad Y would be top top and
bottom um then we're going to do b14
button 1 actually B 1 equals TT K dot
capital B 4 button button and then pop
up and then we'll say the text equals
okay and then the command here we're
gonna have the command V leave mini now
we haven't defined that yet but that was
what I was right about to define up here
so this will will define it right there
and then we'll do B 1 dot pack we don't
need any parameters there it will just
naturally go underneath the label and
then we'll do pop up dot main loop so
it's this is like a little miniature
instance of tkinter so now it's real
quickly go ahead and define leave mini
empty parameters and then here you just
do pop up dot destroy and that's it so
um so we'll go ahead and run that real
quick and the option was say alright
save save settings
okay agree so we go file save settings
let's say and it says not supported just
yet we hit OK no problem and just out of
curiosity I can't remember I already try
this in the past or not but what if we
just instead of leave mini throw and
pop-up destroy since that's such a
simple function there let me try that
really quick
yeah it looks like that works too so we
actually don't need that leave mini
function since the only thing this
function does is run another function
that has no parameters then all we just
need to call this right it's only really
the case when you want a function to run
another function with many parameters or
maybe if or maybe you want to run
multiple functions with embedded
functions that sort of thing
then you would need it but yes so
actually we don't actually need this
little mini function there the more unit
so that's a little cleaner so now we've
got pop-up message all handled now
curiously my ICO did not disappear
interesting in the past the ICO
disappeared because there's a little
slight override but for whatever reason
we're not having it so I guess I'll
leave I'll leave it there okay all right
um so that was easy enough we made the
pop-up functionality and now what we're
ready to do is go ahead and add more of
the many options I think we'll go ahead
and do that in the next video so stay
tuned for that
if you guys have any questions or
comments on this video go ahead and
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support subscriptions and until next
time